hi Farah I couldn't agree with you more
I mean the issue of monitoring teachers
performance and how teachers go on and
carry on the job is exceptionally
important in fact I in the technology
field where where I come from the issue
is never the students and the students
can learn and live with technology
pretty quickly in many cases what we do
of the teachers and how the teachers
actually can convey and can scale up to
to meet the students expectations I
would also add that in today's world our
students are become true multitasking I
mean they're used to studying from a
book writing their homework but at the
same time doing stuff on the pc chatting
to a couple of friends receiving some
messages on on their cell phone and
there's probably music and even a video
running at some point in time and then
used to this kind of like multitasking
rich experience and then you go to the
school and things are kind of like kind
of boring compared to their their
multitasking ability so I agree with you
the problem Israel I'm not sure though
that having one academic Institute would
solve the problem I think it's
that in a way there is a piece on making
sure that education or being involved in
an education career is cool again and
you know in a way if you look at the
faculties of education that we have in
many parts of the Arab world they
usually accept students who are not able
to get into other schools and there are
very few who would really think that
having a career in education in school
so there is one element around promoting
that and I'll making sure that we're
going to get really really good people
and really capable people special people
getting into the education field right
at the beginning and I know that's a bit
of a long term kind of like quest but
then at the second part is around using
technology is there a way to in order to
facilitate access to great lectures
great teachers great curriculums on
using technology many of our people in
many of our governments in the Arab
world are investing a lot on that front
and there's lots of personal computers
and there's lots of investments in in
broadband and telecommunication and you
think that maybe if we add a bit of
content in that maybe if we make sure
that the great lectures are being
actually convey and a teacher will be
comfortable enough using content and
curriculum from other
that would be another very useful thing
too and then the third thing relates to
sort of like the whole reward system and
how do we take care of great teachers in
the schools and and part of that would
relate to results part of that has to
relate to student feedback you see in
the West and some parts of the world is
an official kind of like rate my teacher
kind of thing so I think if we if we add
a bit of that into the into the mix that
will be useful too and then finally it's
the role of the ministries of Education
and how tightly they monitor that and
how seriously are about to rewards and
two great teachers and at the same time
also making sure that those who don't do
very well do not further not progress
may further in the indication career
thank you